[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 les titres de ce
mercredi 20 septembre
changement à la tête du front national
des yvelines mathilde de andrew hayes et
la nouvelle secrétaire départemental du
fn 78 elle remplace françois simeoni
dans un contexte de tensions au sein du
parti au niveau national
réactions dans cette édition un
événement sportif et solidaire le
cinquième triathlon nationale en duo se
tient samedi au domaine du château de
versailles
particularité ce sont des binômes
non-voyants voyant qui y concourent
on en parle avec dominique rocheron
participantes et bernard de gonneville
président du comité des yvelines de
l'association valentin haüy
organisatrice et puis côté sorti une
nouveauté pour la rentrée l'académie
équestre de versailles vous propose de
visiter ses coulisses avec un guide
conférencier vous pouvez découvrir tous
les secrets du lieu fondée par le
chorégraphe bartabas mais avant d'ouvrir
ce journal le comité le comité
interministériel sur le handicap s'est
conclue par une annonce du premier
ministre edouard philippe
l aah l'allocation adultes handicapés
sera revalorisée aide mensuelle pour les
personnes en situation de handicap elle
passera à 900 euros au 1er novembre 2019
et 860 euros dès novembre 2018
augmentation bien accueillie par les
bénéficiaires yvelinois même s'il reste
encore beaucoup à faire écouter et là je
trouve qu'il ya encore beaucoup trop de
choses qui n'ont pas été traités par le
gouvernement justement je voulais juste
parler l'aider
de la dotation d'état qui va être papa
supprimer totalement mais très très très
réduits ce qui fait d'eux en parle de
300 millions de cette année qui est
quand même été retiré dans les
collectivités ce qui va empêcher les
communes aggravation dans les communes
pour la mise en accessibilité
alors qu'on attend ça fait des années et
des années qu'on attend une est vraiment
déçu de 7,17 choses qu'on ne prend pas
en compte l'âge concerne en france plus
d'un million de personnes en situation
de handicap
je vous le disais dans les titres le
front national des yvelines a un nouveau
patron la conseillère régionale de
mathilde de andrew hayes 32 ans a été
nommé secrétaire départemental du fn 78
l ex candidate aux législatives remplace
françois simeoni en poste depuis mai
2016 et décision actée lors d'un bureau
politique extraordinaire cette semaine à
paris changement de tête comme dans neuf
autres fédérations départementales au
moment d'une crise en interne au parti
frontiste
dans ce contexte il est donc important
pour mathilde de andrew est de fédérer
autour d'elle j'ai toujours été très
adepte du bas du dialogue de l'unité de
tous les patriotes au delà même des
sensibilités ou des sociologies et qui
va être l hiver c'est pour cela il est
enfin les films sont très intéressantes
à ce niveau là parce que c'est une
diversité dans la géographie une
diversité dans les files vous avez des
délits comme trappe les mureaux mais
vous avez versailles et puis vous avez
aussi leur succès des petites communes
de campagne très calé ruralité donc
voilà c'est cette diversité là il faut
savoir parler à tous ces gens là ça va
aussi parler à toutes les tendances et
et voilà je pense que j'ai aussi été
choisi pour faire exemple contacté par
notre rédaction françois simeoni n'a pas
donné suite à nos sollicitations
elle et sénatoriales approchent j - 4
avant le scrutin au programme ce
dimanche et dernier focus ce soir sur
les candidats aux élections
à la gauche qui part dit
et pour ce scrutin dans les yvelines
quatre listes au total sont en lice pour
obtenir des sièges de parlementaires les
explications de nicolas kirillovitch et
nicolas landry ils étaient unis dans
cinq circonscriptions des yvelines lors
des dernières élections législatives
communistes écologistes socialistes et
radicaux de gauche partent eux divisés
dans la course aux sénatoriales
nelly duthu conduit la liste l'humain
d'abord du parti communiste avec en
point d'orgue la défense du progrès
social
aujourd'hui on ne peut que pour sa
techno nos projets ne sont pas encore
assez
comment notre objectif n'est pas encore
assez comment pour avoir trouvé la
candidature commune même constat pour
l'ancien député écologiste de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines entre 2010
et 2012
anny poursinoff elle présente la liste
europe écologie les verts dans ces
élections sénatoriales
chacun va être sur ses positions garder
la tête de liste ia qu'un élu ça doit
être moi et chaque à dix ans ça on est
dans une impasse c'est triste mais c'est
comme ça et puis bon par ailleurs ça
permet aussi
2 de mieux connaître les convictions des
uns et des autres c'est vrai que
l'écologie c'est quand même quelque
chose de très différent du reste des
programmes de
nos collègues pour le parti socialiste
la liste unie à gauche pour les yvelines
sera conduite par sandrine grand gang
objectif obtenir au moins un siège de
sénateur le parti socialiste reste le
parti qui a le plus d'élus à gauche dans
ce département
donc nous on appelle l'ensemble des élus
à s'ils veulent qui est une vraie
pluralité au sénat qui ils veulent que
vraiment on puisse avoir un vrai débat
démocratique et que la gauche soit
représenté il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'autres possibilités que de renforcer
la liste que je présente de son côté le
prg présente une liste de rassemblement
de la gauche des écologistes du centre
et des indépendants
nous avions des réserves vis-à-vis du
gouvernement nous avions des réserves
vis-à-vis des positions exprimées par
une partie de la gauche
puis nous avons notre propre identité
mais nous sommes pas seuls le prg
puisque nous avons rassemblé quatre
autres partis autour de nous et nous
souhaitons que cette gauche cette
ouverture au centre soit aujourd'hui
représenté visible mais aussi et surtout
entendu par les élus du territoire
le risque de cette division la gauche
pourrait perdre les deux sièges détenus
jusqu'à maintenant
catherine tasca décidé de ne pas briguer
un nouveau mandat
philippe esnol lui présente une liste
composée d'élus locaux de centre droit à
noter enfin aucune candidature de la
france insoumise a été présenté dans les
yvelines dans le cadre de ce scrutin et
pour refermer cette page politique
l'île de france n'oublie pas simone veil
l'hémicycle du conseil régional sera
rebaptisé au nom de l'ancien ministre
décédé en juin dernier la cérémonie se
tient demain en ouverture de séance à 15
heures en présence du président du
parlement européen et de l'un des fils
de simone veil et direction maintenant
le camp militaire de versailles satory
des députés de la nouvelle commission de
défense nationale ont été invités sur le
site ce mardi matin
l'armée de terre a présenté à cette
occasion son armement et ses différentes
actions sur le territoire français et
étrangers retour sur cette journée avec
michael et ni d'euros
l'armée de terre l'opération séduction
sur le camp militaire de versailles
satory pour la première fois les
responsables ont invité ce mardi 19
septembre les nouveaux députés de la
commission défense nationale un groupe
renouvelé à 90 % en juin dernier on a un
vrai défi relationnel et d'acculturation
vis-à-vis de ces nouveaux députés et
ensuite parce que on va sans doute
écrire une nouvelle page de notre
histoire militaire avec un regard tourné
sur la remontée en puissance de nos
forces
et donc c'est un projet qu'on va
construire ensemble les élus ont pu voir
des blindés des drones des
démonstrations de déminage et des
dizaines d'armes dans le plus ancien
nous avons le dos qui est un fusil de
précision et nous avons la minime une
mitrailleuse légère ici qui toutes les
deux sont en rotation maintenant depuis
plus de 20 ans dans nos armées au total
cinq ateliers de 20 minutes étaient
organisées sur la matinée un programme
nécessaire sur les 30 députés présents
quand on est à la commission de la
défense nationale et des forces armées
il est important de savoir à quoi
correspondent ces forces d'années où on
voit ici des matériels qui servent à nos
forces armées
et puis on peut échanger avec les
militaires sur leurs préoccupations et
leurs besoins c'est très important et
puis ça nous permet de voir l'évolution
de nous impliquer de pouvoir en parler
avec eux encore plus de fierté
les députés devraient voter dans les
prochains mois une hausse du budget de
la défense de 1,6 milliard d'euros par
an sur l'ensemble du quinquennat
des chiffres qui pourraient permettre à
la france d'avoir la première armée
européenne et la deuxième au monde selon
le président emmanuel macron la ryder
cup c'est dans moins d'un an la coupe du
monde de golf est le troisième événement
le plus regardé au monde un enjeu majeur
pour les professionnels du département
la cci à versailles yvelines chambre de
commerce et d'industrie organisé un
speed meeting business pour faciliter à
les rencontres entre les acteurs mélanie
poké ils sont hôtelier gérant de golf ou
encore restaurateurs et participe à la
première réunion de la cci versailles
yvelines
autour de la filière golfique en ligne
de mire la ryder cup de saint quentin en
yvelines
il faut plus voir la ryder cup comme
étant une extraordinaire opportunité
pour valoriser
le golf dans les yvelines pourquoi parce
que la ryder cup en fait c'est le
troisième événement sportif le plus
médiatisé au monde que le golf en france
le golf français n'est pas très connu
dans le monde tout simplement la france
n'est pas une destination golfique pour
les clientèles étrangères et que
justement la ryder cup va pouvoir mettre
en avant cette filière environ 70000
visiteurs seront attendus par jour sur
le golf de saint quentin en yvelines
imaginez des package faire remonter des
besoins plus d'une centaine de
professionnels ont échangé durant cette
matinée des package avec une synergie
hôtelière qui me paraissent extrêmement
important ainsi qu'une remise en
question des services qu'on apporte à
nos propres clients voire surtout les
clients étrangers
ils se remettent en question est ce
qu'on est à la hauteur de leurs de leur
vision du gold ce qu'ils recherchent et
de bien sûr va développer de nouveaux
services d'autres réunions sont prévues
durant l'année le premier coup de petter
de la ryder cup sera donné le 28
septembre 2018
ils ont pour objectif las vegas la
finale du challenge paris saclay ce s
2018 c'est demain c'est à partir de
18h30 au royal factory à versailles
si start up innovantes s'affrontent pour
gagner leur billet au cs le consumer
electronics show de las vegas l'an
prochain on en parle avec nos deux
invités gérard bacheliers président de
la cci versailles yvelines qui organise
ce trophée et lambert traîneau rassis
yojiro lift start-up finalistes qui est
basée à montigny le bretonneux bonsoir
messieurs
on commence avec une question pour vous
gérard bacheliers pourquoi avoir monté
ce challenge paris saclay ce passait pas
le premier challenge pour le cs las
vegas puisque comme on a organisé un
l'année dernière pour 2017 on a emmené
deux lauréats sur donc à las vegas pour
assister au cs de 2007
alors ce challenge ces chalands sont
organisées dans le cadre de la plate
forme open innove qui est une plateforme
qui a été créée il ya deux ans par la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines
et donc nous
organisant régulièrement des challenges
et des soirées de rencontres qui
s'appelle ap innove et ce challenge cvs
on a souhaité le l'organiser dans le
cadre justement spécifique de paris
saclay parce qu'on pense que paris de
chaque lycée est important pour le
développement économique des deux
départements de l'est des îles et et de
l'essonne et de l'essonne et donc honda
cette nécessité de mettre en avant
justement les entreprises innovantes de
de paris saclay et on a donc reçu 40
dossiers
on a sélectionné six finalistes
équiperait qui se présenteront demain
donc à une soirée un pli nov
il y aura deux lauréats qui seront donc
amenés désigné et on à las vegas sur
leur paye le voyage et l'hôtel las vegas
alors lambert retrait noyau de jirau
livre déjà su vous pourriez peut-être
présenter en quelques mots votre start
up elle développe une technologie
novatrice qui est basée sur la mobilité
inclusive
oui tout à fait on a développé une
solution de mobilité innovante qui
permet à des personnes à mobilité
réduite de se déplacer aussi bien assis
que debout donc personnes à mobilité
réduite au sens large
donc ça va de la personne en situation
de handicap à les personnes avec un
vieillissant tout avec un handicap
moteur léger et pourquoi justement vous
êtes vous aligner sur ceux sur ce
challenge pourquoi y participer alors
ben déjà comme vous l'avez dit je suis
basé à montigné donc la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie versailles
l'insee c'est ma deuxième maison mais en
fait on rentre typiquement dans le scope
que soit donc du cs ont deux
ce qui a été indiqué par rapport à paris
saclay il faut savoir qu'on est une
start up qui est issu de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin qu'on est
accélérée à l'x up l'accélérateur de
l'école polytechnique il a couru j'ai
suivi une formation à hec paris donc
voilà on est en plein dans le bassin de
paris saclay dans ce bassin de paris
saclay alors justement gère en
particulier de demain comment on va se
dérouler cette finale il ya six
finalistes giraud lift que j'ai dit mais
également énergie skweres mouna poste me
tempo et et eun supervising comment va
se dérouler os cette finale demain la
soirée va se passer en deux temps en
fait il ya des interventions près
préalable de plusieurs personnes de
xavier dalloz en particulier qui est le
correspondant crs français à las vegas
et qui va présenter l'intérêt d'aller
justement au cs las vegas travers en
aura d'autres présentations qui vont
donc d'orange est aussi d'edf lab qui
vont présenter les intérêts aussi du cs
las vegas 2018 mais ce qu'il réalise
avec des start up donc eux-mêmes voilà
donc là dans la deuxième partie
la deuxième partie se déroulera avec
justement les présentations des pics
j'ai les pitchs des finalistes est donc
un choix va être réalisée par le comique
donc adieu prix en fait à prix du jury
qui a déjà été choisi mais qui a pas été
révélé et puis un prix du public
donc les deux prix sont remis demain
pour les deux lauréats qui vont être
amenés à las vegas donc voilà
très rapidement ce que on a déjà a
dépassé le temps allait hausser see you
de las vegas c'est ce serait quelque
chose alors c'est pas le signe au pardon
c'est le cef désole le cms d'aller
d'aller à las vegas ou et ça représente
quoi pour une start up comme la vôtre
bah c'est une énorme visibilité
c'est un c'est le show numéro 1 sur des
technologies comme le nôtre par exemple
hardware et software
donc c'est vraiment une énorme
visibilité et puis c'est un premier pas
qui sera fait sur le marché nord
américain puisque c'est un des marchés
qu'on contente d'accéder lui plus
rapidement possible après l'europe merci
lamberth renora d'avoir été avec nous et
merci également à gérard bacheliers
l'envers traîneau ratio de jirau lift la
start up qui est finaliste demain du
challenge paris saclay acs la veille las
vegas et gérard barc bacheliers pardon
je vais y arriver
le président de la cci à versailles
yvelines qui organise cet événement
merci à vous deux autres événements
jusqu'au 24 septembre c'est la semaine
nationale du chien guide l'occasion de
pour les écoles d'échangés avec le
public à buc le centre d'élevage et
d'éducation des chiens guides de paris
recherche des familles d'accueil
leur rôle est essentiel dans la
formation du show camille lambert a
rencontré aimé well une chienne d'un an
qui aidera bientôt une personne
malvoyante
mais wayne non
allez à ta place à papa oui et ça c'est
grave ce n'est encore qu'une élève mais
à onze mois mais ouais se débrouille
comme une pro rester à sa place ne pas
courir auprès de ses congénères et
marcher au pied un enseignement complet
pour faire d'elle un bon chien guide
agnès sa famille d'accueil suit ses
progrès depuis ces trois mois est arrivé
mais où elle donc au mois de février
juste avant le départ en vacances au ski
donc elle a commencé à arriver trois
quatre jours et les partis qui suit avec
nous à la montagne
et en fait depuis le début se passe
vraiment très très bien c'est vraiment
une très bonne élève
bon moi je suis un peu pendant subjugué
par les capacités et les compétences
qu'elle peut avoir est bien le rôle
d'agnès dans la formation de mai où elle
est essentielle c'est elle qui lui
apprend les bases de l'éducation et la
familiarise avec d'autres environnements
la futur chien guide est suivi par un
éducateur bientôt mais où elle passera
six mois à l'école de buc
elle sera ensuite remise à une personne
déficiente visuelle en fonction de son
caractère
la personne qui s'occupe des dossiers
des déficients visuels et qui les
connaît arrive déjà à faire un peu à
celui-là il irait bien cette personne là
on va essayer en attendant quillan qu'il
en est du casse ont baissé en termes de
rythme en terme de finesse que ça passe
et puis apprendre à gagner 0 mise notre
problème à l'heure actuelle c'est
effectivement que nos déficients visuels
ils sont en attente de deux ans environ
avant d'avoir un chien guide
parce que l'éducation prend énormément
de temps chaque année les chiens guides
de paris re met 45 de leurs compagnons
encore 120 personnes sont en attente
ces chiots n'ont que quelques mois mais
eux aussi deviendront de véritables
guides pour leurs futurs maîtres l'école
recherche des familles d'accueil pour en
prendre soin or mais aussi solidarité le
cinquième triathlon nationale en duo se
tient ce samedi à partir de 8 heures 30
au domaine du château de versailles
particularité de cet événement organisé
par l'association valentin haüy les
coureurs sont en binôme non voyants et
voyant 50 binômes seront présents au
programme 3,6 km de course à pied 10 km
en tandem et 1 5 km en canoë et kayak
bonsoir dominique boucheron vous êtes
aveugle et allait participer justement
ce triathlon samedi on va en parler dans
un instant et bonsoir bernard de
bonneville président du comité des
yvelines de l'association valentin haüy
qui vient en aide aux personnes
déficientes visuelles justement un petit
mot déjà pour commencer sur cette
association
quelles sont ces différentes missions
oui bonsoir l'association valentin hui
est la plus ancienne association qui
vient en aide en aide aux aveugles et
aux déficients visuels puisqu'elle a été
fondée sous louis saez
entend lui était un gentilhomme
d'origine hollandaise qui vivait à
l'époque de louis saez et qui s'est
rendu compte que les aveugles ne devait
pas être des parias mais que si on
s'occupait d'eux on pouvait les aider à
retrouver une vie normale et donc il a
fondé à l'époque ce qu'on appelait
l'institut royal des aveugles qui est
devenue maintenant l'institut national
des jeunes aveugles qui existe toujours
à paris et à côté de l'hôpital necker et
puis 7e cette association après s'est
développée au niveau de chaque
département et en particulier au niveau
des yvelines dont les responsabilités et
la déficience visuelle est un vrai
problème en france puisque ils font
compte en france environ 70000 aveugle
et 2 millions de déficients visuels
excessifs ne font qu'augmenter avec le
vieillissement de la population
et justement alors sur cet événement on
est du on est sur du sport est-ce que ça
finalement un bon moyen aussi
d'intégration sociale d'épanouissement
pour ces personnes c'est aussi pour ça
que ce moyen du sport a été choisi oui
le but de notre association c'est agir
pour l'autonomie et donc pour aider les
déficients visuels ou les aveugles à
acquérir de lock up de l'autonomie il ya
de la formation il ya de l'informatique
il ya des sorties et il ya du sport
presque le sport est un très bon moyen
de retrouver l'autonomie je pense que
dominique vont en parler en connaissance
de cause justement dominique pour ce
triathlon en du lot c'est votre première
participation ou l'annoncé inquiète
c'est la 5 avec vous la voulez fait
depuis peut-être pourquoi se lancer dans
ce défi
finalement ce triathlon
en duo vous l'avez dit c'est un défi
c'est un défi j'ai pratiqué le sport
quand j'étais jeune et je l'ait arrêté
parce que la déficience visuelle
s'installait j'avais l'impression plus
rien n'était n'était possible et puis
j'ai eu il y a une petite dizaine
d'années je me suis remis au sport par
l'intermédiaire du tandem et et s'est
présenté ce premier triathlon en 2010 ou
pour moi c'était le défi à relever est
ce que j'étais capable de d'enchaîner
trois épreuves
dans deux que je ne pratiquais pas du
tout je me rappelle il ya de la course à
pied du vélo entendait il ya là et du
kayak
j'étais jamais monté dans un kayak et
puis donc le premier défi c'est envers
soi-même quoi se dire est ce qu'on est
capable de et puis aussi montré montrer
aux autres que certes on est déficient
visuel certes on est porteur d'un
handicap mais on est aussi capable de
faire des choses et notamment faire du
sport et c'est aussi une excellente
journée de partage avec des voyants
qu'ils donnent leur temps pour nous et
très très belle journée sanou voyante
avec qui vous allez être rendu au
comment se prépare pour ce ce genre de
défi vous l'avez distincts un défi le
binôme on le rencontre auparavant il
faut se préparer avec lui comment on
commence à 7 il ya deux il ya deux
possibilités soit ce sont des guides que
l'on connaît de longue date avec qui en
pratiquent déjà du sport d'accord donc
voilà soit on le découvre le jour même
bon il suffit d'un petit peu
d'entraînement parce que évidemment
alors un vélo c'est facile on est
derrière et on se laisse ans est entre
guillemets guider pour la course à pied
c'est un tout petit peu plus compliqué
et il ya une technique de guidage que
chaque aveugles ou malvoyants possède et
il faut que le guide s'y adapte donc
c'est un petit peu de un petit peu
d'entraînement avant mais c'est avant
tout beaucoup de vigilance de la part du
guide qui
qui doit avoir les yeux pour deux
personnes bernard will aussi l'idée de
qui est cette compétition audio c'est de
créer une symbiose entre le non voyant
et le voyant qui qui va l'accompagner
pendant ces quelques cette quinzaine de
kilomètres de compétition oui c'est une
des dans l'adn de notre association
c'est la parité est au plus haut niveau
de l'association comme tout en bas nous
nous efforçons toujours qui est parité
les voyants et non voyants à la fois
dans les gens qui décident d'aller vers
les gens qui travaillent dans les gens
qui managent aidant les gens qui
participent aux activités
donc voilà c'est de notre bonheur d'être
ensemble et c'est vraiment l'une des
caractéristiques de notre association
petit tour de table qu'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter à ce triathlon on va commencer
par vous donniez qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter à vous pour ceux de leur
famille qui pleuvent pas qu'il pleuve
pas et que tout se passe bien que chacun
y trouve
il trouve son bonheur et beaucoup de
plaisir dans la pratique du sport et
voilà c'est je suis pas forcément dans
la compétition et des résultats même si
quelque part on y va quand même un petit
peu pour concourir et faire de bons
résultats mais c'est pas ne s'est pas
l'essentiel de la pour moi en tout cas
c'est pas l'essentiel de la journée
côté associations qui font ce beau on a
eu un mois de septembre très compliqué
mais je crois que la météo va être avec
nous et qui va faire beau et je souhaite
que beaucoup de gens viennent nous voir
et je vous remercie de nous avoir
invités pour faire un peu de publicité
sur cet événement parce que plus il ya
de gens qui viendront nous voir et qui
seront sensibilisés au problème du
handicap visuel et peint plus en aura
deux moyens pour aider nos amis aveugles
ou malvoyants et je rappelle que ce
cinquième triathlon nationale en duo
c'est ce samedi à partir de 8 heures 30
au domaine du château de versailles et
plus d'infos sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran merci à
mes deux invités dominique boucheron et
bert et bernard de gonneville d'avoir
été avec nous pour parler de ce
triathlon c'est grégory avant de
refermer ce journal l'académie équestre
de versailles a rouvert ses portes le
week-end dernier après une pause
estivale
une nouveauté pour la rentrée une visite
des coulisses de l'académie avec un
guide conférencier il était déjà
possible de la visiter seul mais avec
mais sans explication est désormais le
visiteur peut découvrir tous les secrets
du lieu et le travail des écuyers
camille lambert
[Musique]
c'est un corps de ballet équestre avec
ces artistes qu'ils soient humains ou
chevaux à l'académie équestre de
versailles
fondée par le chorégraphe bartabas les
10es cuillé et leurs montures forment un
couple uni des années sont nécessaires
pour arriver à ce résultat
la relation entre l'écuyer le cheval
c'est vraiment la base du travail ici
c'est pour ça bien sûr que bartabas
lui-même va essayer de choisir quel
écuyer va monter quel cheval avec des
respects de proportions physique mais
surtout de caractère donc ça s'adapte se
sont tous les matins que les écuyers
passe une heure à faire travailler
chacun de leurs chevaux chaque écuyer en
moyenne 4,5 monture à faire travailler
un travail que les curieux sont invités
à découvrir lors de visites guidées
vous avez le nom du cheval vous avez sa
race et ici vous avez le menu une
plongée dans les coulisses à la
rencontre des stars du spectacle comme
bad les experts en cabrioles ou des
salles d'importance ce que j'appelle
toujours le saint des saints
c'est à dire la sellerie est un lieu
extrêmement fermé d'habitude mais qui va
permettre de voir les selles les
harnachements et tout au long de la
visite on va tout simplement voir le
travail on va voir les palefreniers au
travail on va voir les écuyers venant
chercher leur cheval
le prépare en lui parlant on va voir la
nourriture des chevaux également donc
c'est vraiment le quotidien à l'intimité
l'intimité de l'académie martin ans tête
accueillera des groupes de 30 personnes
maximum pour partager ses secrets et
anecdotes sur la vie à l'académie les
visites sont proposées tous les
dimanches à 10h30 sur réservation
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal c'est à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]